cette habitante de paray le monial est
excédé dès que j'ouvre ma fenêtre le
bruit qui émerge du parc en face de chez
moi est insupportable dans ce parc
trente cinq mille catholiques se sont
rassemblés pendant huit semaines et
certains soirs selon cette riveraine les
nuisances sonores sont encore plus
importantes comme témoin de cette vidéo
enregistrée la semaine dernière pendant
les gens qui applaudissent les gens qui
crient les gens qui tapent des pieds
la situation serait devenue invivable le
matin ça nous réveille vers 8h30 le soir
ça nous empêche de dormir puisque ça ne
cesse pas avant minuit
ça c'est une nuisance très importante
pour de nombreux parodien comeneurs
d'autres riverains ne supporte plus
d'entendre des bruits
j'ai eu mes petits enfants en vacances
mon ami mais c'est pas possible on peut
pas dormir chez toi c'est comme si on
avait un festival festival à côté de
chez moune est chez nous qui dure deux
mois
tous deux dénoncent l'inaction des
pouvoirs publics mais pour le maire de
la ville
ces plaintes sont irrecevables quand on
reçoit des milliers de personnes dans
une ville de 10000 habitants
ça fait forcément du bruit la question
qui se pose de savoir est ce que c'est
une chance pour la ville ou pas et moi
je dis oui c'est une chance pour la
ville pour la population dans le parc où
se déroule ce rassemblement les
participants rencontrés disent avoir
conscience de la gêne occasionnée mais
prendre toutes les précautions pour être
le plus discret possible
oui effectivement les du brion
et on travaille ces questions là chaque
jour on seront remis en question les
points qui n'ont pas été et on va voir
les personnes qu'ils voient qu'ils sont
liés à ces dérives quoi et en fait je
crois qu on avance quand même bien et
dans le bon sens
lorsqu'on est en ville on fait attention
justement pas être trop bruyant et y'a
pas faire trop peu justement plus pas
les déranger
ces rencontres se termineront dimanche
soir de quoi redonner le sourire à ses
livres jusqu'à l'été prochain